I'm selling all the retro gaming stuff from the 80s,
Most of them are Gameboys,
PC Engine,
SNK Neo Geo Systems
SEGA, and many others.
Before I started this shop, I was in the video game business
That was way back in the 90s if I'm not wrong
I got very serious into this gaming business,
and that's where I am now.
All the retro stuff I have now, are from my personal collection through the years.
I'm interested in retro gaming collection,
In terms of playing, I'm not a true gamer
I don't really play games that well.
I started collecting because I liked the items,
When I find that they are funny or cute,
or if they intricate me, I will put them aside.
Most of what I have today, that is how I collected them.
Because at that point of time,
I would not have known that people will collect retro gaming stuff.
For myself I like playing with Gameboys
Like the very first Gameboy Classic,
The grey one that came with Tetris
That is still my favourite game.
For me this is the easiest game to play
for young and old,
until today, I think some of the older folks are still looking around for this game.
The first game that I ever bought was with my own pocket money
At that time, it was around $28
It was a Nintendo Game & Watch, Manhole
Those Game & Watch in the shop now are for sale but,
a lot of customers are looking for one because it makes them think back on their childhood.
Some of the Game & Watch sets are worth a lot of money now
From as low as $80-90 to
brand new, sealed in box at a few thousand dollars.
Retro gaming is like collecting antiques
At that time, the most expensive system
was the SNK Neo Geo
Some of the brand new games cost up to about S$800.
When I started to sell it, it was considered a rich man's game machine.
The one piece that is worth a lot in the retro gaming market now,
is the Metal Slug, USA Version
My dream is actually to open a retro gaming museum
but it seems like I can't fulfill that dream
Due to circumstances such as difficulty in finding a space
So instead of letting keeping all this
I might as well sell them to real collectors
For casual gamers, they would think its a waste of money
But for those who are into retro gaming,
when they see this collection,
they might get quite envious.
My wife for one, says that it is a waste of money and space
till the day she realised that some of the items are worth so much.
Most of the retro gaming machines I have now are in good working condition.
The technology at that time is very different from now.
Those games are burned into EEPROM
Until today they are still working because there are less moving parts
I think it will last for many years to come.
Seriously, new gaming sucks.
this is part of the reason why people go back to playing retro games.
for example, Super Shinobi Shadow Dancer, beats any of the PS4 games, hands down.
Graphics are fantastic
They spend a lot of time and effort to create beautiful graphics
but, no gameplay and replay value.
Spend $80, 6 hours complete.
During my overseas trips,
I like to visit gaming shops
So I saw retro gaming in Japan
but in Singapore, there is none
So I thought, why not start a shop in Singapore?
I'm proud to be the first,
but I'm not sure how it would go from here on out.